und mal endlich gute Nachrichten und
zwar für alle die jeden Montag auf Demos
die Öffnung von Nord Stream zwei fordern
die olle ostsee-röhre wurde geöffnet
meine Damen und Herren nur halt von
innen
explosionsartig Nord Stream 1 und 2 an
vier Stellen kaputt gemacht aber bitte
das ganz wichtig bitte keine
vorurteilung bei diesem Fall sind noch
jede Menge Fragen ungeklärt zum Beispiel
welche Nation dahinter steckt oder wie
genau die russischen Kampftaucher das
gemacht haben ja das ist ja alles noch
offen was für ein Krimi was da genau
passiert ist weiß niemand da wird ein
U-Boot im Spiel gewesen sein im Internet
wird sogar über Delfine spekuliert hat
er eigentlich direkt unter Wasser mit
dem Torpedo zerschießen
arbeiten oder Drohnen ja was ist da
passiert das ist ein Loch ganz
offensichtlich in der Leitung
wartungsroboter der Missbraucher würde
der missbraucht würde ja
ein wartungsroboter wurde missbraucht
keine weiteren Fragen es war die
katholische Kirche meine Damen und
Herren
es gibt Indizien ja der Kreml hingegen
sagt man müsse erst die kommenden
Ermittlungen abwarten natürlich würde
mich nicht wundern wenn es am Ende heißt
Marderschaden mal wieder ja natürlich
sie wissen schon der gefürchtete Ostsee
unter Wassermarder
ich fürchte Putin schickt uns hier eine
Art Botschaft im Sinne von Dinge können
kaputt gehen oder auch schöne neue
Norwegen Pipeline habt ihr da
hoffentlich passiert der nichts und wie
sie sich natürlich denken können hat die
EU direkt mit einer knallharten Antwort
reagiert die EU droht bereits mit
Sanktionen gegen wen auch immer
da wird wer auch immer aber schön blöd
gucken oder ich behaupte wem auch immer
geht der Stift tatsächlich zu den
Tatsachen hat wer auch immer heute mit
seinem Stift vier ukrainische Regionen
mal eben zu Russland gemacht ja mit
einer Unterschrift im Grunde wie so ein
räudiger Autodieb der sich selbst den
Fahrzeugbrief ausstellt weil dann ist es
ja legal ich vermute mal die
Besitzurkunden für Moldau das Baltikum
und Sachsen liegen längst in seiner
Schublade aber ist nur eine Theorie aber
keine Angst meine Damen und Herren im
sogenannten energiekrieg schlägt unsere
Bundesregierung jetzt gnadenlos zurück
wochenlang müssen wir sagen hatte man ja
das ungute Gefühl die Ampel übt noch
also
stiftet konsequent Verwirrung führt
irgendwelche Umlagen ein und schafft sie
dann auf den letzten Drücker wieder ab
aber das ist vorbei Freunde denn jetzt
kommt der 200 Milliarden Euro
gaspreisdeckel hier der Chef kann seinen
Stolz kaum verbergen ich habe einmal
über andere Gelegenheit gesagt die
Maßnahmen die wir ergreifen sind ein
Bums man kann sagen dass es hier ein
doppeldumms
nimm das Putin einmal Doppel Wums mit
scharfe Soße ohne Zwiebeln
tja tja aber ganz kurze Frage wirklich
nur am Rande warum meldet sich der
Kanzler live aus einem Aquarium aber
er wird seine Gründe gehabt haben so
meine Damen und Herren winzige Details
sind noch offen also zum Beispiel wieder
Deckel funktioniert aber hey das findet
sich alles sicher ist eins Christian
Lindner befüllt jetzt den sogenannten
stabilisierungsform mit 200 Milliarden
ja und das tolle ist das tolle ist
dieses Geld kommt gar nicht aus dem
Haushalt denn dann müsst ihr sicher von
seiner Geliebten Schuldenbremse trennen
nein das Geld kommt von
woanders
genial oder das holen wir uns aus der
Zukunft und basteln daraus Achtung einen
Abwehrschirm gegen Putin hinter diesem
Abwehrschirm warten Aufgaben vor uns
hinter dem Abwehrschirm bleiben wir
solide hinter dem Abwehrschirm hinter
dem Abwehrschirm hinter diesem
Abwehrschirm hinter diesen Abwehrschirm
hinter dem Abwehrschirm und hinter
diesem Abwehrschirm hinter diesem
Abwehrschirm hinter
der Schlange geht's weiter
viel schlechter kann man das nicht sehen
ja Udo Lindenberg meine Damen und Herren
ich meine jeder von uns mag
abwehrschirme logisch aber wie wäre es
denn mal mit ehrlichen Schulden statt
kreativer Buchführung nur so als
Anregung aber komm sind wir dankbar dass
der Deckel jetzt wohl kommt und dass die
blöde gasumlage gestrichen ist
wochenlang haben wir über diese Umlage
gestritten und dann ist dem
Finanzminister plötzlich was
ungeheuerliches aufgefallen die
Christian Lindner masterglas
bahnbrechende Erkenntnisse auf die man
selber nie gekommen wäre die gasumlage
Macht die Gaspreise noch teurer das war
die Christian Lindner master-glas dann
brechen die Erkenntnisse auf die man
selber nie gekommen wäre
[Musik]
sie das wussten sie das wenn man zu
einem Betrag einen anderen Betrag
addiert wird der mehr ja
die meisten Experten sagen am
gaspreisdeckel geht jetzt kein Weg mehr
vorbei um eine Pleitewelle zu verhindern
zwar wären Direktzahlungen an Betroffene
deutlich besser aber dazu ist dieses
Land logistisch leider nicht in der Lage
warum auch immer und das Problem mit den
vielen Schulden ist ja auch längst
gelöst die Schuldenuhr wird wohl bald
schneller laufen aber aus
Stromspargründen wird auch sie
vorübergehend ausgeschaltet
siehste genau deshalb habe ich meine
elektronische Waage weggeworfen ja um
Strom zu sparen hoffentlich da bete ich
wirklich hoffentlich ist mit dem Doppel
Wumms auch das alberne alpha-rüden Duell
zwischen den Herren Harbeck und Lindner
endlich beendet ja hoffe ich aber ich
fürchte nein sie streiten zum Beispiel
weiter über AKW-Laufzeiten außerdem
warnt Robert Habeck nicht ganz so
unrecht dass die Bürger jetzt vor lauter
Freude über den neuen Deckel zu wenig
Energie sparen möglicherweise private
Haushalte haben zuletzt deutlich mehr
Gas verbraucht als in den Vorjahren was
ist denn los mit uns warum können wir
plötzlich nichts mehr ab das fragt man
sich ja schon lange nicht mehr
abgehärtet sind viele von uns
denn wir lernten Wärme zu konsumieren
statt zu frieren
Brennstofflieferanten und
Heizungsinstallateure aber auch
Automobilhersteller beschleunigten den
verweichlichungsprozess unserer
Gesellschaft ja jemand muss endlich
diesen verweichlichungsprozess stoppen
heizschäming ist das Schlagwort der
Stunde ja wer jetzt schon die Heizung
hochdreht outet sich als egoistischer
Drecksack
wobei es sind ja gar nicht die deutschen
denen schon im September ständig kalt
ist sprechen wir es doch einmal offen
aus was man heute nicht mehr sagen darf
sehr friert denn in einer Tour und macht
sich damit zu Putins Helfer wer denn na
genau Frauen sind das diese Pointe wurde
Ihnen präsentiert von die
der dümmsten Frauenwitze mit Oliver
wir hoffen dass der neue superdeckel
auch bald kommt und dass er hilft
unseren Bäcker zum Beispiel im
Mittelstand insgesamt plus den ganzen
Stadtwerken die akut von der Pleite
bedroht sind woran wiederum Wasser
Müllentsorgung und ÖPNV hängen aber
meine Damen und Herren es kommt leider
noch viel dicker breaking news ja der
Pack mir doch einer an den Zapfhahn in
Deutschland gibt es bald kein Bier mehr
ja
das könnte passieren könnte passieren
eine dramatische Entwicklung und wir
schalten mal direkt live zu unserem
Reporter Dennis knossalla in eine
fränkische Familienbrauerei denn es wie
Ernstes die Lage Achtung Oliver Hammer
Einstieg auf dem deutschen Biermarkt
braut sich was zusammen
diese Kupferkessel in denen sonst
fleißige Bakterien die leckerste rülps
Grundlage der Welt herstellen
die sind leer
das kann gut sein dass wir im Winter
frieren aber es ist ja noch viel
schlimmer wir werden im Winter nüchtern
frieren können Sie mir mal erklären wie
ich die Politik der Ampel nüchtern
ertragen soll soll ich Klebstoff
schnüffeln zum Beispiel aber was ist
denn konkret das Problem Jana was wohl
kohlensäuremangel ja akuter technische
Kohlensäure ist ein Abfallprodukt der
Düngemittelherstellung und für die
wiederum braucht man Erdgas gleichzeitig
gehen die Preise für Hopfen Malz und
Braugerste durch die Decke Ergebnis eins
der widerlichsten Worte dass die
deutsche Sprache je hervorgebracht hat
bierflation doch das 0,2 Gläschen für
mittlerweile zwei Euro zwei Euro zehn
oder sogar zwei Euro 20 tut dem
Geldbeutel ganz schön weh 220 das werde
ich Schmerzgrenze ich würde diesen Preis
zahlen um halt Geselligkeit
du ja pflegen man muss sich schon
überlegen wie viel man trinkt
dem Punkt sind wir jetzt
sich überlegen wie viel sie trinken und
die Politik tut nichts wo bleibt die
Ampel Task Force Bier
stromdeckel gut und schön aber wann
kommt endlich der Bierdeckel gut das
müssen wir sagen die Ampel hat natürlich
mehrere Baustellen gleichzeitig es ist
alles nur noch so traurig hier Brauen
sie jetzt in ihrer Not schon das erste
Radler ohne Kohlensäure die Marke heißt
schalsteiner alkoholfrei
das einzig Schale Schalsteine aber kein
Wunder dass Berlin nicht eingreift in
die bierkrise mit diesem
partikanzler an der Spitze heute Abend
können Sie sich ein Bier na da sind noch
zu viele Dinge zu tun heute wird das
wohl noch nichts aber ich werde mir mal
ein Deal gönnen das nicht an nicht ohne
Alkohol
ein Bier das nicht nicht ohne Alkohol
ist ein Satz der überhaupt keinen keinen
Sinn macht
wladimir Putin hat sich gezielt überlegt
wie treffe ich die Deutschen gasan zu da
lachen wir drüber aber Bierhahn zu
das tut weh naja was ich noch nicht
verstehe die Kohlensäure brauche ich
doch eigentlich nur für die Abfüllung
damit das Bier länger haltbar ist ganz
genau weg und an dem Punkt werden wir
Deutschen zurückschlagen ja wenn wir
nämlich alle zusammenhalten und unser
Bier einfach viel schneller austrinken
also bevor es schlecht wird ja hat er
irre in Moskau praktisch schon verloren
ja vergessen sie trinken für den
Regenwald ich sage saufen gegen Putin
das klingt wie ein Plan denn es ist
vielen Dank
es wird ihnen ohne Frage klar sein auch
wenn wir jetzt wohl eine gaspreisbremse
kriegen ändert das natürlich nichts an
der Gas Knappheit auf dem Weltmarkt
genau deshalb war Olaf Scholz gerade auf
großer buckeltour im Nahen Osten unter
anderem in Saudi-Arabien bei Prinz bin
Salman also
the prince formally known Eska Schoki
zersäger danach gab es noch einen Deal
mit den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten
das heißt wir kaufen in unserer
Verzweiflung jetzt wirklich von jedem
Land das nicht die Ukraine angegriffen
hat auch von Katar wo schätzungsweise
6.500 Menschen beim Bau der WM Stadien
gestorben sind hier Tasse kanzleransage
an die cataris ich wünsche Kata viel
Erfolg für seine Gastgeberrolle bei der
allerersten WM in der Region und ich
wünsche der katarischen und der
deutschen Fußballnationalmannschaft ein
erfolgreiches Turnier
ja da guckt er der Scheich ne da guckt
er verstehen Sie was Scholz da sagt
erfolgreiches Turnier wenn man die
Buchstaben völlig anders anordnet und
welche hinzufügt
ergibt das achtet die Menschenrechte was
scholzer gesagt hat wirklich übrigens
eingetütet hat er
137.000 Kubikmeter Flüssiggas für uns so
viel kam früher an einem Vormittag durch
Nord Stream 1 ist wirklich wahr aber
andererseits
ja was soll er machen was soll er machen
kleinvieh macht auch Gas und immerhin
ist der Olaf seinem Ruf als klimakanzler
gerecht geworden und hat mitten in der
Wüste einen Baum gepflanzt denn sie
wissen ja ein Mann muss im Leben drei
Dinge tun cumex Banker treffen
das Treffen wieder vergessen und ein
Baum pflanzen
das einzig konkrete was der Kanzler
ansonsten von dem Trip mitgebracht hat
war Corona leider ja gut meine
solche Demütigungen wie auf der Reise
sind wahrscheinlich die gerechte Strafe
für unsere jahrelange Abhängigkeit von
Putin und für unsere Heuchelei beim
Thema Rohstoffe ich sag's mal so der
Deutsche wir alle wir haben uns daran
gewöhnt dass alles was dreckig ist oder
giftig gefälligst woanders aus der Erde
gepopelt werden soll ich sage nur
Franken ja ja sie haben ganz richtig
gehört sie haben ganz richtig gehört
Fracking diese Sendung die heute-show
war immer für Fracking bitte nicht bei
Youtube nachgucken
verdammtes Internet Fracking ist bei uns
zwar verboten aber es hat sich da
technologisch durchaus was getan in den
letzten Jahren also ruhig mal out of the
box Denken sowie einer der klügsten
Politiker unserer Zeit zu diesen
Energiequellen gehört auch in
Deutschland nachzudenken prüfe und zu
machen ob Fracking in Deutschland
möglich ist Süder sieht das
fracking-potenzial aber nicht in Bayern
sondern in Norddeutschland
ja ist ganz lustig ich sehe das Fracking
Potenzial vor allem direkt unter dem
Haus von Markus Söder
ja es gibt hier bei uns tatsächlich
relativ große Schiefergas vorkommen zum
Beispiel in the Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
bzw
frecklenburg-vorpommern
experten schätzen
Experten schätzen Deutschland könnte
sich 14 Jahre am Stück komplett mit
eigenem Schiefergas versorgen 14 Jahre
das wären zehn Jahre länger als die
Kanzlerschaft von Olaf Scholz
eine vom Bundestag eingesetzte
Expertenkommission sieht in ihrem
neuesten Gutachten nur geringe Risiken
fürs Grundwasser und auch nur geringe
Risiken beim Thema Erdbeben das juckt
aber kein stimmt es dass sie von der
Kommission alle sogar ihre Urlaubsplan
miteinander abgestimmt haben falls der
Bundestag in dieser Frage jetzt
plötzlich Beratungsbedarf hat dass sie
reden und Antwort stehen könnten aber
sich noch niemand gemeldet hat bei ihm
das ist in der Tat so
leute leute leute leute leute leute
Leute sag mal
jetzt ruf doch bitte mal irgendwer
diesen Mann an
damit der endlich in den Urlaub kann das
gibt's doch gar nicht ja gut die Politik
regiert ja gerne nach Umfragen und 55
Prozent der Deutschen sind immer noch
gegen Fracking ja wir
lassen uns lieber Gas aus den USA
liefern per Schiff mit freckerando oder
wie das heißt inzwischen geht fracken
auch ohne schädliche Chemikalien
hauptsächlich mit Wasser und Sand ich
behaupte das Verfahren braucht vor allem
dringend ein besseres Image
jetzt neu nachhaltiges Fracking fast
ganz ohne Chemie unsere bewährte
Rezeptur aus Wasser und Sand ist 100%
Veggie und glutenfrei schon Hildegard
von Bingen fragt im Garten des Klosters
Ruppertsberg kam aber nur zwei Meter
tief nur Fracking löst Verspannungen im
Erdreich und befreit von störenden Gasen
und es tötet nervige Wühlmäuse
außerdem liegen die größten Gasfelder in
Niedersachsen falls es also doch
Erdbebenschäden gibt dann auch am Haus
von Gerd stimmt nein jetzt überzeugt
Fracking der sanfte Einlauf für Mutter
Natur
so so
nämlich gut gut so wahr gehört fracken
würde uns kurzfristig nicht helfen aber
man könnte ja schon mal die
Genehmigungsverfahren verkürzen wir
können es uns schlicht nicht mehr
leisten eigene Bodenschätze einfach nur
rumliegen zu lassen anderes Beispiel
Lithium
Lithium braucht man unter anderem wissen
sie für Akkus in E-Autos mitten im
Oberrheingraben liegt das wahrscheinlich
größte Lithium vorkommen Europas
trotzdem gibt es da nur pilotbohrungen
weil sie anders Bürgerinitiativen Angst
vor Erdbewegungen haben wenn aber für
unser Gas in Holland konkret in
Groningen die Häuser zerbröseln können
wir damit super leben ja da können wir
richtig super mit leben ja gerade was
Rohstoffe angeht sind wir echt voll die
Assis alle Mann wirklich Deutschland
benimmt sich wie so ein Typ der sein
eigenes Klo nicht dreckig machen will
und deshalb immer beim Nachbarn groß
macht warum zwei Toiletten putzen
da würde ich jetzt erstmal nicht
reingehen Alter
übrigens Klopapier ist alle bis morgen
ja das sind wir das sind wir
Seitenwände ist gefragt liebe Zuschauer
auch in den Gehirn wobei es einem
natürlich schon menschlich leid tun kann
was zum Beispiel die Anhänger der Grünen
gerade alles durchmachen rein emotional
manche
Kohlekraftwerke laufen länger die heute
show vor der plötzlich mehr Fracking und
auch der Atomausstieg zum 31.12 fällt
erstmal aus es geht wahrscheinlich
anders in der Weltlage aber es macht ja
dennoch was mit der Psyche dieser
Menschen
im idyllischen Emsland unweit vom AKW
Lingen liegt die Jürgen Trittin
Nervenklinik hier ist mein spezialisiert
auf die Behandlung von grünen die wegen
der ampelpolitik in einer akuten
psychischen Notlage sind ja also das mit
der Laufzeitverlängerung diese Woche das
war jetzt einer zur vier
da ist irgendwas in dem zerbrochen meine
Diagnose seelische Kernschmelze
ja
bitteschön das war schon homöopathisch
Globuline ja klar
drei Sekunden später haben sich die
Grünen Patienten mit Hilfe schwerer
Psychopharmaka beruhigt in der
Konfrontationstherapie müssen sie sich
stundenlang ein Foto des AKW Isa 2
anschauen
[Musik]
den Insassen der Klinik dämmert langsam
dass in all den Jahren bei den Grünen
ihr Leben quasi weggeworfen haben alles
woran du hier geglaubt hast stimmt
plötzlich einfach nicht mehr die
Deutschen wollen keine Atomkraft wir
machen nicht mit bei dem kriegen Robert
Habeck ist ein guter Politiker alles
Lüge neulich war ich auf der Seite von
der FDP und ich fahre so kurz davor mir
den Mitgliedsantrag runterzuladen
Mittagessen
es gibt ausschließlich genmanipuliertes
Gemüse
wir haben jahrelang zu Unrecht Panik vor
Gentechnik in der Landwirtschaft gemacht
selbst das war Bullshit
natürlich
in speziellen Achtsamkeitsübungen müssen
die Grünen ihren inneren Frieden
wiederfinden während gleichzeitig Anton
Hofreiter bei Lanz über schwere
waffenfach simpelt
hat pt91 das sind kaum Pferd gesteigerte
T-72 dann können wir bitte den Toni
ausmachen ich werde total aggressiv bei
dem Gelaber
du Tatjana
ich verstehe Dich ja auch ein Stück weit
aber das ist halt Realpolitik und tief
in unserem Innersten bleiben wir ja
Pazifisten
du dummer du
damals
sie brauchen jetzt all unsere Liebe
hallo Leute Ich bin's der
[Musik]
heute-ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
Scheiß und Lied
memes wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
Kanal
was zur Hölle ist ein meme Ersteller
[Musik]